SCP-049 Vs SCP-106.
Will the classy, intellectual Plague Doctor
with a deadly touch finally be able to defeat
the ruthless, calculating Old Man with an
unstoppable fetish for pain?
Let’s find out.
Both have deadly anomalous abilities concerning
touch - the Plague Doctor stops hearts, and
the Old Man melts flesh.
However, it’s unlikely that either would
be as effective in combating each other as
they would against non-anomalous humans.
But it’s in the other anomalous effects
that a clear winner comes through.
While SCP-049 can create an army of zombies,
numbers mean nothing in SCP-106’s pocket
dimension, so if ever the fight was taken
there, we think 106 would have a clear advantage.